[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie j'ai la
joie d'être en présence de Michka
Assayas qui est déjà venu c'est un
enfant de la Vallée de Chevreuse voilà
qui a grandi depuis mais vous avez des
souvenirs là-bas vous y avez passé une
partie de votre enfance si vous êtes
encore assez attaché je crois tout mon
enfance toute votre enfance voilà alors
Michka ça y est moi j'ai la joie de vous
voir ici en plateau parce que bon pour
ceux qui ne savent pas ça m'étonnerait
vous êtes journaliste pour différents
médias la presse la radio surtout en ce
moment depuis plusieurs années c'est que
la radio
et puis et puis qu'est-ce que vous me
faites troubler vous avez créé des
livres aussi des romans bon bref on va
revenir là-dessus et alors le petit
dernier justement ce livre c'est un
entretien avec mot de Berthomier ça
s'appelle very good trip c'est le nom de
votre émission sur France Inter qui
passe tous les soirs de 21h à 22h vous
aviez démarré en 2015 avec une
hebdomadaire le dimanche après-midi on
vous a promis
et qui dure toujours avec une grille
d'été spéciale aussi dont on parlera
tout à l'heure voilà et donc virgule
trip c'est donc le nom de votre émission
sur France Inter et après il y a écrit
une histoire intime de la musique alors
dites-moi si je me trompe j'ai
l'impression que cette mot de Berthomier
elle vous a un peu accompagné de du
berceau à maintenant pour pour voir un
peu entre vous la musique quels sont les
parallèles intimes qu'est-ce que sont
les fils comment ça vous a animé depuis
très tôt finalement oui oui enfin ça a
été vraiment comme une sorte de
psychanalyse sauvage
c'est à dire que bon comme souvent il y
a des éditeurs qui quand vous avez
quelque chose qui est connu ce disent ça
serait bien d'en faire un livre alors en
l'occurrence une émission de radio et
moi j'avais pas envie de faire ces
livres finalement qui ont pour moi pas
beaucoup d'intérêt qui sont les les 100
albums incontournables les au titre
qu'il faut avoir entendu une fois dans
sa vie où je sais pas quoi et et
au fond quelque chose on s'est dit qu'il
y avait peut-être quelque chose qui
avait jamais été fait qui était de
raconter le rapport intime et affectif
qu'on a à la musique et que je sorte
justement de ma peau d'historien d'un
cyclopédiste de présentateur de la
musique des autres mais ce que je suis
toujours bien sûr mais disons que je que
j'éclaire un peu les coulisses parce que
comme comme en fait quand je suis à la
radio
je fais quelque chose qui est assez
particulier finalement parce que je je
parle souvent de choses que je ressens à
travers la musique des autres et donc
finalement il y a des gens qui vont se
demander mais c'est qui ce type qui nous
parle qui nous parle parfois de sa vie
etc donc on sait pas qui il aide ou il
sort et donc c'était l'idée de au moins
en fait de part de partir de ce point de
départ et d'en faire quelque chose
d'intéressant
extraordinaire
vous commencez donc c'est très jeune
votre premier flash musical votre
premier coup de cœur
je sais plus aussi c'était un disque de
twist de ma mère qui avait acheté un
disque qui s'appelait ça existe plus ce
format c'était ce qu'on appelait les 25
cm vous savez qu'il y avait les 17 cm
qui était les 45 tours les 30 cm c'est
les albums il y avait le 25 cm qui était
entre les deux donc elle avait un
c'était je paye avec 4 ou 5 chansons par
face et c'était dans le twist il y avait
il y avait il y avait une fille qui se
déhanchait sur la pochette et ça me
fascinait et et et ma mère écoutait ça
quand elle venait à la maison
pardon c'était gay c'était joyeux
c'était très joyeux très joyeux c'était
moi j'ai enfin bon alors pour beaucoup
de de d'enfants j'imagine c'est juste un
moment agréable mais moi j'étais obsédé
par cette musique je je m'asseyais
devant le haut-parleur
et je j'écoutais religieusement elle
habitait à la semaine à Paris et elle
venait le week-end alors c'était ça
faisait partie de la fête quoi oui oui
exactement ça faisait partie de ce qui
me sortait du quotidien parce que mon
père
qui était plutôt
qui était même tout à fait écrivain
scénariste
passait ses journées à son bureau ou pas
quand il était là et et dans un silence
monacal
on était élevé mon frère et moi par une
une sorte de nounou oui une nounou qui
venait de Hongrie et
oui c'est ça et qui était enfin qui
avait une vie plutôt austère enfin donc
c'était puis faut quand même se rappeler
que dans les années 60 et encore le
début des années 70 il y avait deux
chaînes de télévision en noir et blanc
donc qui en plus il y avait aucun
programme l'après-midi donc si vous
voulez les enfants s'ennuyer beaucoup
dans le bon sens aussi d'ailleurs et il
rêvait et la musique jouait un rôle de
de d'évasion ah oui de d'aller voir
ailleurs parce que vous êtes allé très
tôt en Angleterre du coup j'ai
l'impression que vous laissez quand même
une liberté un peu dingue ce que vous
avez rejoint Olivier votre frère
et vous l'avez rejoint mais je sais de
quel pays vous aviez 11 ans
oui tout seul non mais oui on avait
quand même une cousine qui était qui
vivait dans la banlieue de Londres et
qui nous le jeu mais enfin on faisait ce
qu'on voulait oui bah c'était un peu cet
enfant des années 60 et 70 qui étaient
un peu le contraire de celle qu'on vit
aujourd'hui on est surprenanté surveillé
ou les parents veulent tout savoir nous
on pouvait faire les pires conneries
possibles et imagine oui c'est ça
c'était vraiment ça que vous aviez lu le
journal intime de votre père
je crois que les parents se mettent pas
dans la tête des enfants et ils le
laissait traîner
il pouvait pas imaginer que ça nous
intéresserait mais comme comme dans
toute famille il y avait des il y avait
beaucoup de non-dits donc je j'utilisais
j'utilise cette matière pour un peu
comprendre ce qui se passait et ce qu'on
me disait pas quoi et vous aviez aussi
un demi-frère qui était en pension à
saint-jean-de-bédine à Versailles
exactement pareil c'était un peu la
solitude avec Olivier
on croise avec qui on parle hongrois
d'ailleurs
après vous êtes donc passionné pour la
musique c'est c'était ce qui faisait
vivre vibrer finalement j'ai
l'impression et même déjà au collège
vous aviez dites-moi si je me trompe de
cette envie de transmettre votre
enthousiasme très cher de convaincre
c'était facile ou pas
pour pas après tous de toutes c'est à
dire que je je sais pas j'avais c'est
comme si j'avais une mission
vous savez j'ai vu il y avait un
documentaire sur Éric Clapton et qui
très tôt
ok une enfance aussi très particulière
parce qu'on lui faisait croire que que
en fait que ça sa mère était sa sœur
enfin il y a des il y avait beaucoup de
non-dit dans sa famille et donc il s'est
réfugié dans la musique comme une espèce
de de
oui de monde parallèle où on pouvait
rêver enfin bon et
donc il disait que pour lui le blues tel
qu'il le percevais parce qu'il cherchait
des disques rares il les échangeaient
etc et c'était il avait l'impression
qu'il devait être le le
l'évangéliste de cette musique parce que
cette musique de libération de
délivrance et de révélation sur soi-même
et je et je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
il fallait que ça reste pour moi au
contraire j'avais l'impression qu'il
fallait que que tout le monde
partage ça parce que c'était
un message oui de libération pour moi
enfin j'avais presque un esprit
religieux finalement et puis à un moment
vous avez compris aussi que un morceau
de musique pour faire exploser le monde
oui ça c'était c'était très fort pour
vous oui c'est-à-dire que je vous savez
on vivait dans un monde qui était quand
même très austère il faut dire ce qui
est je vous parlais de la télévision en
noir et blanc faut aussi se rappeler ce
qui était l'école moi j'ai encore connu
l'école d'avant mai 68 ou c'est à dire
que moi j'ai pas eu de blues mais je
suis passé juste à côté
et il y avait un maître d'école qui nous
mettait des tornioles enfin c'était un
peu l'éduquer enfin les instituteurs
étaient comme des adjudant et on a eu
des profs mais au collège qui était qui
avait une éducation assez militaire donc
si vous voulez c'était très austère
alors évidemment il y a on entendait
parler de Woodstock les cheveux longs la
libération sexuelle donc ça on
comprenait pas parce que c'était
complètement en contradiction avec ce
qu'on vivait
on avait l'impression que c'était
c'était presque l'interdit enfin ça
allait aussi avec des journaux
satiriques à acquérir le futur Charlie
bon Charlie Hebdo actuel
enfin tout tout l'idée de d'un monde où
tout était possible alors que dans notre
vie d'enfants rien n'était possible mais
après c'est vrai que moi j'avais la
chance d'avoir des parents qui étaient
très libéraux au sens classique du terme
qui c'est-à-dire enfin pas ma mère parce
que quand elle était là il faisait la
police mais mais mon père il y avait il
était cool il était très cool et il est
très très bien veillé il était âgé aussi
il était plus un grand-père qu'un père
finalement donc vous a laissé
qui qui ouais pour le meilleur pour le
pire surtout pour le meilleur
après vous avez ce qu'on voit à travers
ce livre aussi c'est l'évolution de vos
goûts donc la jeunesse tout feu tout
flamme ses punk jeunesse c'était ah non
quand j'étais très jeune c'était hippie
pause tipi c'était ce qu'on appelait la
musique
Genesis Pink Floyd tout ça ces trucs là
j'étais très après en fait ça c'était un
peu la musique de mon frère c'était des
choses que je auxquelles je me
raccrochais après il y avait des trucs
que j'ai même et après il y avait toute
cette question aussi de qu'est-ce qui
était cool qu'est-ce qui était pas cool
on était un peu snob donc il fallait pas
très élitiste très élitiste en musique
ouais ça c'est sûr et ça a changé
le temps parce qu'au début j'étais très
fanatique je tire que quand il y a eu le
punk c'était une remise en cause totale
de tout ce que j'écoutais avant donc il
y avait beaucoup de gens de de mon âge
autour de moi qui comprenait pas que
c'était une mode extravagante que
c'était ridicule etc moi non je dis mais
non c'est c'est une destruction
créatrice comme on dit et il y a une
musique qui est apparue après qu'on
avait jamais entendu dire que vous ayez
des gros comme joyeux etc enfin et et là
c'était mon histoire à moi c'était
cette musique là d'après la prepunk
c'était
trouver quelque chose à dire de
personnel sur cette musique parce que ça
correspondait à mon expérience du monde
c'est à dire que en effet comme je vous
écrivais j'avais cette espèce de rêve
d'un monde multicolore psychédélique
avec les Beatles tout ça enfin qui
m'émerveillait et puis
ça a été le réveil a été a été violent
parce que on a on a pressenti que ce
monde génial émerveilleux qu'on nous
avait entre guillemets vendu ne
viendrait pas donc c'était le début de
la crise économique le chômage
oui c'est ça ça arrivait tout ça
arrivait en France on a eu la les vagues
de licenciement on a oublié mais la
sidérurgie en Lorraine etc mais c'était
c'était terrible ce monde
post-industriel ou finalement toute
cette société dans laquelle on avait
baigné n'existait plus mais presque on a
l'impression que le monde s'est effondré
sonopa et donc le c'est impression de
désolation de vide de de
de d'anomalies tout à coup devant lequel
dans lequel on devait se lancer il y
avait rien c'était c'était vertigineux
et la musique traduisait ça une certaine
musique
ils ont toujours été en avance mais oui
vous n'avez dit il y avait des groupes
comme marksad et cetera disons que les
les anglophones ils avaient une
tradition de de musique dans la fin
comment dire pas dans la rue mais dans
les bars dans les il y avait les petites
salles plus proche des gens liées au
folklore etc enfin comment dire la
musique était pratiquée par tout le
monde ici c'était différent
boy scout qui chantait autour du feu de
bois il y avait les Petits Chanteurs la
croix de bois et tous ces trucs là mais
c'était c'était parfois lié au jeu de ce
catholiques aux éclaireurs enfin tout ça
c'était c'était pas très sexy quoi et
puis il y avait quand même la chanson
qui avait la chanson contestataire en
France qui était très très forte mais
qui était très dur un peu plus vieille
quoi c'était pas tellement
d'énergie quoi
non non non non et alors après vous avez
enfin vous avez quand même beaucoup
écrit dans la presse déjà vous avez
démarré avec les uns par exemple
après vous avez écrit aussi en le
dictionnaire du rock ça c'était très
important vous l'avez comment dire
augmenter absolument
et ça ça a marqué un tournoi aussi dans
votre carrière ce dictionnaire ah oui
parce que au fond ça a été pour moi une
un travail presque
alors là en fait qui était
l'aboutissement de de tout ce que
j'avais vécu de tout ce que j'avais fait
et qui devait clore cette façon toute
cette obsession pour la musique et je
croyais en avoir terminé pour faire une
sorte de cathédrale quoi la musique et
c'est vrai que ça a été un travail
titanesque en fait
et
mais la musique m'a jamais m'a toujours
rattrapé
d'entretien donc il y a eu un vinyle
en rapport avec ça mais parce que vous
donnez 300 titres oui alors voilà on est
en fait on a fait l'éditeur et l'idée de
faire une édition limitée avec un double
vinyle c'était les titres dont on a eu
les droits gratuitement ok c'est ça mais
ça fait quand même on s'est débrouillé
et alors justement qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce retour au vinyle ah je
pense que c'est
une sorte de désillusion par rapport à
une prétendue après tendue progrès
technologique voilà il existe bien sûr
mais je pense que on vit dans un monde
où qui manque beaucoup de charme et et
donc
c'est toujours un peu la même chose on a
gagné en même temps on a perdu c'est à
dire que
par exemple on peut aujourd'hui en effet
écouter la musique quand on veut on a
lancé sur un stream un site de streaming
on peut aller sur Youtube enfin on peut
faire ce qu'on veut enfin dire que la
musique a plus aucune valeur au sens
elle est gratuite quoi vous avez un
désabonnement bon voilà et quand vous
passez à côté de téléphone vous avez pas
l'impression de dépenser de l'argent bah
c'est un peu la même chose même si vous
avez un abonnement bon et donc
le vinyle c'est ça ça reste je pense une
nostalgie et nostalgie même finalement
adopté par des gens qui ont pas de
raison d'être nostalgique parce qu'ils
étaient trop jeunes pour l'être mais ça
ça fait rêver d'un ça fait rêver d'un
monde où la musique était sacrée avec
quelque chose de sacré et vous qui était
très sensible à l'esthétisme des
pochettes ça doit vous manquer c'est
aussi ah oui c'est vrai oui oui c'est
vrai mais maintenant d'ailleurs
vous savez il y a une étude qui a été
faite qui a établi que les gens qui
achetaient des vinyles
finalement les acheter pour les pour
décorer leur intérieur plutôt que pour
écouter vraiment et mettre poser sur une
platine
des choses bon peut-être des gens des
espèces particulièrement
passionnés font ça des des fanatiques du
son parce qu'effectivement il y a le son
analogique opposé au son numérique alors
c'est vrai il y a mais font franchement
je trouve que moi j'écoute sur Spotify
comme tout le monde et
non ah non les CD ça c'est fini j'ai
plus parfois j'ai des vinyles mais oui
j'aime bien quelquefois
on est obligé d'acheter un vinyle si on
veut un album c'est rare c'est rare mais
ça m'est arrivé
et dites-moi alors cette été qu'est-ce
que vous nous concoctez en général l'été
vous nous préparez des des spéciales
avec un ou soit de d'artistes parce que
on a eu beau oui on a eu Bob Marley qui
est un livre d'ailleurs maintenant on va
en parler cet été quel est le programme
le programme c'est pas le McCartney
voilà donc une série de 9
épisodes du 1er juillet au 26 août le
samedi oui
il me semble alors bon oui on va donc ce
livre là c'est fait c'est 22 mais c'est
passionnant et puis on découvre l'homme
à travers et puis il y a plein de photos
de la Vallée de Chevreuse
de mon enfance
le charme justement contrairement à ce
qui manque dans ce monde et
du coup après vous avez enquillé sur
Bowie oui parce que en fait c'est c'est
là c'est une en fait c'est c'est une
double commande puisque à l'origine
le France Inter m'a commandé une série
sur David Bowie qui est passé donc en
été 2022 c'est ça et
l'éditeur
content la GM content du succès là de
notre livre c'est dit il faut qu'on
fasse autre chose et
et avec des éditions Radio France ils
sont dit il faut faire un livre cette
série bah oui qui a très bien marché et
mais c'était alors là je me suis arraché
les cheveux parce que en fait vous savez
moi j'écris tout à la radio j'écris tout
vous écrivez comme vous parlez vous
j'écris comme je parle mais le problème
c'est que quand
vous mettez ça tel quel dans un livre
c'est pas possible ah non mais non parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de de répétition
de trucs ça tourne en rond il y a des
retours en arrière enfin on est un peu
perdu et puis là le style n'est pas
adapté à la lecture donc ça a été un
gros boulot de tout remettre en forme
parce que j'ai enlevé beaucoup de choses
et ajouter d'autres choses et justement
mode qui m'avait qui avait qui est une
une excellente
un excellent auteur elle a elle a écrit
d'ailleurs une thèse sur la naissance à
la critique rock aux États-Unis elle a
fait ça à Colombia elle a rencontré tous
les pères fondateurs
c'est c'est donc il est très rigoureux
et rédige très bien et c'est une
universitaire très pointue donc
ce livre Bowie est sorti exactement
aussi parce que j'avais fait une série
il y a 2 ans
elle vient de m'échapper
de de la scène actuelle des jeunes
Français musiciens en deux mots
qu'est-ce que je pense c'est mon avis
est pas enfin je veux dire non mais je
veux dire on est au vidéo très époque là
complètement aujourd'hui
j'adore un groupe qui s'appelle la
féline qui a gagné
et non en fait elle est béarnaise
Carlotti que j'adore j'adore plein de de
de de chanteuse j'adore Philippe
Katerine depuis longtemps après si vous
voulez me demander si je connais bien le
rap d'aujourd'hui et l'électro non pas
tellement c'est pas trop voilà non
il y a plein d'électro que je peux
écouter oui mais c'est un fils qui est
musicien d'électro ah d'accord donc
ouais Antoine
ben j'espère c'est un enfant de la
vallée aussi
à très bientôt j'espère que j'encourage
tout le monde à oui qui sait lire ce
livre et les suivants et à vous écouter
bien sûr sur France Inter à très vite
merci Véronique merci de nous avoir
écoutés et à très bientôt
[Musique]